Oh dayum it is kind of a sausage party
in here
for the record would hit it would hit
more hit hard pass
oh Tom who is this person this is
Monalisa Saperstein my new sales
associate
Monalisa Saperstein does that mean oh
yeah she's my sister my twin sister from
the same mister thank you so much for
hiring Monalisa it means so much to me
even though honestly she's the worse
she's the worst person in the world huge
skank terrible but thank you means a lot
of course gotta keep it in the family
Oh boss man I want to go home early
oh hold on actually hang on you know I
want to quit and never come here again
okay bye I can't believe I used to date
you hold up my dad said that yeah John
Ralphie oh he told me that I had screwed
you out of my business so he was gonna
screw me back any idea why he'd believe
such a thing is so weird that is so uh
you know what honestly not I'm thinking
about it this may be it actually told
him that rent-a-swag was my idea and
that you had stole it from me why would
you say that because my dad is always
riding me for never having a job and I
just didn't want to show that I blew it
again oh and I don't know if this is
relevant but I told him that you made me
sign up for a bunch of credit cards and
then max them out by buying a legal
white Jaguar fur coats probably not
relevant no I don't know all this lying
about me stops now this is my life
please one of you has to tell him the
truth
Oh okay fine you know what I'm gonna do
the unthinkable I'm gonna have a short
honest conversation with my father thank
you we need to focus I want this to be
the best founders week ever okay no more
distractions I'm bored uh let's go have
sex in a tree he'll be back in eight
minutes
why did you have to bring her here I
don't really have any power in this
relationship
I'll think of ideas in the tree anyone's
welcome to join us in the tree oh nice
hey ding-dong can I go home my Tumtum
feels gross and also I hate working I
guess but find someone to cover for you
okay because we're really busy right now
also a lawyer guy called you he sended
really sexy on the phone and I was very
into that like I was like very into that
all right let's set up some boundaries
what's cool for you to say to me okay
okay
I frenched my cousin one time that's
gross I might still be in love with him
please leave all right bye
so I need to ask you something and I
cannot wish Jon Ralphie I wasn't here
please tell me that you're dumping my
sister because I actually may be the
opposite this yours yeah it's mine
I'm pregnant Lemony Snicket oh my god
are you serious I'm gonna be an uncle is
that a real thing is that gonna happen
no no that's too that's too much
responsibility for me I gotta I gotta
find a new way out of this well I wish
he told me I mean obviously we need to
talk about our future maybe I could sell
the business so we could use the profits
to put a down payment on a house or
something
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Cupid thank you had a dum-dum face
that was hilarious I was huh
so you're not pregnant this isn't yours
no do you know how many different pills
I take on birth control or otherwise
there is no way that I could be pregnant
with a human baby thank God yes Tommy
has his life back let's go hell is wrong
with you man that's my sister nah I'm
just kidding man she's the worst
you got you a bullet baby
congratulations
jean-ralphio Saperstein as per his last
will and testament we will now listen to
his favorite song
bend over by Lil Jon featuring Tyga okay
okay bought it they bought it do you
have the insurance money
no down hit a bro time to start a casino
in Tajikistan
what a lovely offer but I think not you
know I've got my hands full with my
practice my other business is my two
terrible children I don't think I have
time to be mayor hold up I will do John
Mayer again daddy someone said a fire in
your car because you took too long and I
got bored mommy please oh no no there's
no money oh my dad no problem that's
fine um I'll just destroy this office
then give her some money
it's easier
baby can I borrow your car for a month I
already lent you my car do you not know
where my car is oh I'm so sick of the
third degree it's like didn't cop I'm
Jessie let's sneak out move aside dating
Monalisa is awesome except that I live
in constant fear for my life so I guess
it's time to do the mature thing and
have someone else dump it for me hi Mona
Lisa hi I'm Anne Perkins I used to beat
Tom okay we can do this but I will bite
you is that a screw vert no I do not
want to fight no no I just want to talk
to you woman to woman because I know Tom
pretty well you know is a Tampin because
I cannot crack that little bitch's code
don't you know you used to drive me nuts
he is a total control freak I mean you
have to put a coaster down on every
surface and the worst part is they're
all made out of pictures from Diddy's
Instagram
dude he's on Instagram how do I know
that he was on instagram you jagweeds
who are you yelling at but jagweeds why
are you still in front of me you I think
it's great that you're cool with Tom's
financial situation are you talking
about Tommy owns his own business yeah
but he had to borrow a lot of money when
you're not around Tom drinks tap water
what excuse me you're broke yeah super
broke are you upset about that hmm yeah
cuz I don't f with poor Z's but thanks
to a warning from my new best friend I
don't have to okay we're done you're
awesome and I don't even usually like
Puerto Rican chicks I'm not I mean it
shouldn't matter but you're breaking up
with me oh man that sucks
that's right it's over let's go down
oh she's coming Tom okay
desperation time follow my lead what
lead me put you over what the
mother-effing cing essing effing king f
is going right now sorry Mona Lisa we
can't keep our hands off each other that
is accurate oh it's all finally very
clear all the times you were like oh no
Tom's no good for you and all the times
you tried to break it off with me I
finally get it
you guys want a threesome what's no we
do not wanna have a threesome with you
well let's not rush to judgment I mean I
say we hear out gross Tom good luck you
still owe me a blanket oh she's got a
screw loose am i right
actually she's not the one of my life I
would call crazy look I still don't
think we should date oh me neither I've
been single for an hour now and it's the
two notes still it to hook up though yo
do you want to have a threesome with us
yeah okay cool sweet all right I know
what that my name is gonna be how much
strength this jacket Oh curly sue that
jacket is so ugly you should just take
it it's 15 for the day 40 for the week
thank you like we share your business
Mona Lisa did you order the champagne
for the client party tonight did i
murder the what for the what what what
what what are you even talking about
right now okay we need to discuss your
work habits okay sure but after I take a
quick nap because ecstasy takes forever
leave my system no we're doing this now
you need to start putting in more of an
effort and start respecting my authority
around here or else one where else I'll
fire you what did you just say I said if
you don't shape up I'll fire you do you
understand you are so friggin sexy right
now I could crap my pants
yeah what are you doing mmm-hmm a lot of
hot be in here tonight oh look at that
chunky hunky go over there and talk to
him and find out what his deal
no I'm not gonna talk to some other guy
we're together you can't check out other
guys that's the deal
or else it's over between us you
understand hmm Tommy laying down the law
a little feisty I like that okay
I'm gonna go get a soda do you want to
have sex somewhere after I do that sure
you